hey friends welcome back to the deep
dive snippet so there is this common
misconception that we have in our
culture obsessed with productivity and
hustling and stuff that we need to
control our time we need to manage our
time time is this thing to be tamed uh
and in this little clip which is a clip
from our conversation with oliver
berkman the author of four thousand
weeks we're gonna talk a little bit
about that so hopefully you enjoy it
let's roll the clip yeah i think that's
the that's the balancing act like that
that i found as well in my life without
a child um is where i will try my best
to set an intention for the day of like
this is the this is the one thing that i
want to do and i will try my best to
broadly stick a time block in the
calendar for when i will want to do that
one thing knowing that like to be honest
if a friend was like hey do you want to
grab lunch i will prioritize social life
over work generally and the way i think
of it is like the rest of the things i
want to do today
are a might to do list rather than a
to-do list
and i i'm i'm still experimenting still
still trying to figure out like what's
like a realistic maximum number of
things i'm allowed to have on that list
because i think otherwise for me the
temptation is there i'd be like oh well
i'll call my grandma and then i'll call
my mum and then i'll call my aunt and
then okay so that's the relationship box
takes oh then i need to message about
eight different friends and i need to
send thank you cards and christmas is
coming up so let me send great gifts
and then i need to do all these
different things checking all these
videos that are coming out and the list
just swells whereas what i've been
trying to do recently is just be like
i'm only allowed to do three things on
this list and if after that i still have
more time and i feel like doing like
work then at that point i can i can
freestyle it but i just never get
through just just even those three
things on the list and one of the things
i really liked about you also like at
the end of the book you have a sort of
practical advice section for those of us
that are like okay
enough philosophy and we get to the tips
uh you talk about um i think sort of uh
sort of having having like a maximum
number of things that you're allowed to
do something to that effect yeah there's
all sorts of different ways of
implementing this and you'll be familiar
with many of them but this idea of like
limiting your work in progress this idea
of saying like i'm only going to work on
um
a small
a fixed number of of things and i'm
going to complete one of those things
before i allow myself to put another
item onto that queue and obviously you
can do this at the level of like
projects you could say i'm only gonna
have like one major goal
um in my work at a time and you can also
do it to some extent at the level of
tasks right you can be like well these
are the these are the three things i'm
going to do and i'm until i've done one
of them nothing else is coming off that
task list and
uh
you know kanban
boards are an obvious way to implement
this and i've got this idea in the book
about keeping two to-do lists where you
sort of feed items from an infinite
to-do list through a very narrow limited
to-do list um
and again it's just all about like
saying look you're already making
choices your time is already finite
whenever you're doing something you're
already saying no to all the other
things in that moment so now just like
make it conscious and and
and sort of hold yourself to it and
avoid that thing that i certainly am
very prone to i think lots of people are
where
it feels like you're more in control of
things if you just sort of
spread your um attention among 50 of
them yeah
but actually it
isn't because what you're not more in
control you're not making better
progress on them because you just bounce
from one to the next whenever they get
difficult so you just get around it
exactly yeah um i'm i'm finding this for
the book as well which uh one of my
my my writing coach says is normal for a
first draft where i will get 80 of the
way through and then it starts to feel
like uh i need to round off the argument
somehow
but i can't be bothered right now let me
just do chapter eight
and i'm hoping that towards the end of
it then i'll be able to think about this
this kind of stuff hey friends thank you
so much for watching if you enjoyed this
clip then click here for the full
unedited episode and if you like that
then do please consider subscribing to
the channel it means a lot thank you so
much and have a great day